in supervised learning it's obviously
getting toys more mathematical talks
should be thanks for the introduction
not that the previous talk wasn't
exciting but I'll try to you know talk
about some attempts people have made to
formalize sort of different fairness
criteria but I'll actually end on sort
of a note of caution that these criteria
can't ultimately sort of pin down what
fairness means and so when David asked
me to talk about optimization and
fairness I was like I'm not sure there's
much optimization in fairness right now
but you know I'll mention the word
feasible region just to fake it that
make people happy so as Christa sort of
explained very nicely there you know
we've we've seen that decisions based on
machine learning can wind up being
unfair or perceived as unfair without
any explicit wrongdoing and that'll give
one example you know which closely
mirrors one of Christophsis examples so
this the Bay Area you probably one of
you has a start-up and you want to hire
somebody for your startup okay so you
designed this ad you know for hiring a
software engineer you should probably
hire a graphic designer first but let's
say you know you start with a software
engineer for your startup and so you
know this is this is your ad and you
know place this on an advertising
network and you're wondering who should
see this ad okay you want to target
software engineers and you're worried
about gender discrimination because
hiring in tech is very controversial and
you know advertising is the first step
of the hiring plat for pipeline so you
know this this is an important sort of
point of contact there and so how do we
solve advertising our targeted
advertising as a machine learning
problem in practice you know to simplify
it's something like this you start with
you know the features of an individual
which are denote by X such as you know
your browsing history things you've done
on the Internet and in this case I'll
highlight sort of one sensitive
attribute which is gender and I'll call
that a and that need not be explicitly
sort of written down in acts but it
could be highly correlated with acts you
know your browsing history you know
generally you know can be used to
predict gender very reliably and finally
there's a there was a classifier
which decides whether you see an ad or
not okay this is an oversimplification
but let's just see there is a classifier
see which decides yes or no show the ad
or not and what sort of the classifier
trying to do it's trying to predict
whether somebody is a software engineer
because that's the group of people
you're targeting okay so there's a
target variable I call Y which is you
know whether you actually are self when
G or not and I'll assume for this
example that somehow you know if you're
a software engineer you'll click on it
and otherwise you want so I'll identify
that with clicking on it okay so this is
the description of the problem and you
sort of ship that to let's say you know
one of the big advertising networks and
you say you know do this for me
and they come back at you and they say
here are the results of your ad campaign
if you look at precision or this is
sometimes called click-through rate
that's the probability of hitting a
target given that you showed an ad okay
so you show the ad to somebody what's
the chance that they're actually a
software engineer that's called
precision or you know if you identify
the target with clicking it's
click-through rate and this is what ad
platforms optimized this is you know how
they sort of increase revenue they
optimize precision sort of relentlessly
and you know you might see even a plot
this is one one thing they could tell
you you might see a plot like this
precision by gender so you look at men
who saw the ad and you use see that
eighty percent of them actually clicked
on it so that's great and also among
women actually you know women who saw
the ad eighty percent clicked on them
okay so you see you know this is the
same value and it seems like this is
great okay so your precision or you
click-through rate in both groups is the
same but Christoph explained if you
slice the data differently and you look
instead at a criterion called true
positive rate which is somewhere you
flip these two things around you look at
the probability that you actually do see
the ad given that you're a positive
instance so given that you qualify for
seeing the ad what's the chance of
actually getting a positive
classification outcome and this is
called true positive rate or recall and
this is not something at platforms look
at does somebody have an idea of why
they don't look at this
the results are bad yeah probably
sorry yeah you know it's sort of it
requires you to kind of go against your
model right it requires you to like sort
of do things that your model didn't
suggest to estimate sort of among the
people you know that it didn't show the
ad who did I leave or you know like you
have to figure out you just have to
randomly show the ad to people and see
you know among the people who are actual
targets how many of them clicked on it
so it requires some form of exploration
that's not currently in the sort of that
you know pipeline but it's sort of a
measure of inclusivity it says given
that you qualify for a positive outcome
what's your chance of actually getting
it okay and what's perfectly consistent
with the previous results is that
actually your true positive rate by
gender looks awful okay so men who
qualify get it at a eighty percent rate
and women who qualify get it at a forty
percent rate okay so if you think as the
positive outcome as sort of desirable
the positive classification outcome
getting into college getting a job you
know seeing even this great ad if that's
the positive outcome or the positive
thing you want then this is certainly
very concerning okay so a couple years
ago we you know said okay let's think
about this as a kind of a criteria on a
measure of discrimination and so we
formalized this assumed C and Y are
binary so the classifier and the target
are binary and say that a classifier
satisfies Equal Opportunity if you know
the true positive rates are the same in
all groups okay so it's just you want to
you know sort of make sure that you're a
chance of getting the positive outcome
given that you're positive instance is
the same in all groups
so in some sense there's a sense of
having you know an equal opportunity to
get the positive outcome and and in all
groups okay same true positive rate in
all groups we just sort of highlighted
this as a criterion of saying look this
is something people might be concerned
about violations of this criterion are
perceived as unfair so let's highlight
this as a criterion and you can
strengthen this a little bit and you can
say that not only there require the same
true positive rate I also you know
require the same false positive rate
this is you know if some of the negative
outcome the negative classification is
harmful you know you want to also make
sure that you know or if somehow you
know classifying somebody a negative
instance incorrectly as a positive for
instance if that's harmful you want to
make sure the harm is the same in all
groups okay and this one actually has a
very nice mathematical definition you
can just state it as a variable R
satisfies equalized odds if R is
independent of a conditionally on on Y
okay so the the classifier or your score
function or whatever you want is
independent of the sensitive
characteristic conditional on the target
okay so false positive is like if you're
screening for terrorists then you don't
want to be a false positive so I want to
make sure you know if you're in an
airport what's your chance of getting
stopped as a terror suspect you want to
make sure that different groups have the
same rate of being incorrectly
classified as terror suspects you know
like it's it's again it's a social
choice right like it depends on the
application there's no you know there
are situations where you're mostly
concerned about the true positive rate
they're situations where you're
concerned about false positives or both
but yeah that's not somehow you know
good it's not something that you can
decide at generality okay but notice
this means that in general your
classifier R could be dependent on a
there could be a correlation between the
two they don't have to be independent
but the extent to which they correlate
is sort of justified by the target okay
so you can only correlate these
variables if actually the target is also
correlated with a and that's why they
become correlated and in terms of
graphical models I'm not sure this is
helpful to anyone here does somebody
know where the graphical model is okay I
don't but you know it's something about
you know the target separates a and C so
you know that's just a different way of
writing conditional independence and
corresponds to separation in this three
node graphical model okay good so what
are desirable properties of equal
opportunity
realized odds which is why we thought it
was interesting to highlight this first
of all it's kind of optimality
compatible okay so as you're making your
classifier more and more accurate you
are allowed to sort of have a perfectly
accurate classifier so if you just
perfectly match the target that's a root
of an allowed solution and you kind of
don't you know [ __ ] machine learning
you can always kind of allow people to
try to become more accurate and it
penalizes laziness in the sense that it
gives you an incentive to reduce errors
uniformly in all groups okay so you're
not allowed to do something like oh I'm
really I really know what a good
software engineer is among men and so
I'm gonna exploit that and I don't have
much data on female software engineers
so I'm going to just randomly guess
among them okay so this notion would
actually explicitly incentivize you to
go out and get better at classifying
female software engineers okay and I
should say that neither of these two
desert errata is achieved by making just
the classifier independent of a okay so
you know back in the day people often
produce and sort of propose this as a
fairness criterion that your classifier
should just be statistically independent
of the sensitive characteristic but it
actually fails to check and check these
boxes so I don't you know there's still
a range of scenarios where this is a
good thing to shoot for but in general
this is not this is not a good criterion
I should also say that there's no such
thing as fairness through an awareness I
kind of dropped this on my slide dropped
this from my slide decks in 2015 and
then this year there was a panel with
experts who proposed fairness through an
awareness as a solution so I put this I
put this light back on
okay so fairness through awareness is
this idea of removing or ignoring all
sensitive attributes okay so you just
say let's just take my feature space and
just remove the sensitive attribute and
then do whatever want okay and this is
not this is not a good solution
typically because the the other features
subsume the sensitive attributes okay so
you can typically predict them really
well from from the other attributes for
instance your browsing history need not
explicitly sort of disclose your gender
or your race but it's very easy to
predict
your browsing history job application
process if you ask people not to give
their names and age and say can you say
that's that doesn't it doesn't guarantee
fairness yeah I mean and there's
certainly a tension between what's
currently sort of an interpretation of
the law that you can look at the
sensitive attributes and what every
single paper on fairness would suggest
you do right so every single sort of
technical study of fairness had sort of
come up with this insight that you can't
just ignore the sensitive attributes but
yes that's still predominantly what sort
of a corporate lawyer would want you to
do so there's certainly a tension there
and I think you asked that question
before and yeah that's a very sort of
critical point that these things are
currently in and a lot of tension yeah
okay so how would you achieve equalized
odds or equal opportunity this is sort
of a quick technical you know excursion
for the optimizers so one way of doing
this in this the method we had in that
paper is to post process or correct this
should be post processing of score
function no correct their score function
so what's the score function it's any
random variable that's you know has a
range between 0 and 1 and is a function
of your features and your sensitive
attribute okay and for instance the sort
of what's called the base optimal score
is given by the function which is just
the conditional expectation of your
target given the features ok that's sort
of your best estimate of the target
given what you observe observed okay
that's an example of a score function
this is typically not what you can get
this is typically hard to get but it's
kind of you know what's called Bayes
optimal and so what's post-processing
what do I mean by that you just take
your score function as a black box you
don't see how it's trained or you don't
retrain it you just take it as a black
box and you're allowed to apply any
threshold into the score function that
possibly depends on a ok so it could
depend on a and by sort of picking these
different thresholds for different
groups you hope to achieve the
constraint of equalized odds okay but
there's no retraining and there
no changes to the score function so
given a score function what can you do
you can plot the true positive rate and
the false positive rate the point for
all possible thresholds so as you vary
the thresholds from 0 to 1 you can get a
curve of the true positive rate on your
y-axis and the false positive rate on
your ax X's ok so these are all the
points that my score function gives you
for different thresholds and this this
dashed black line is sort of corresponds
to random guessing this is the score
function that or this is kind of the
trade off the trivial trade off that you
get from random guessing with a certain
bias okay as you generally want the
curve to be sort of biased away from
this trivial line you can also look at
the true positive rate or you can look
at these curves by group ok so you now
get our C curve for each of the groups
and you know you see that different
groups of different trade-offs that are
realized at different thresholds ok and
this is where I'm going to use the word
feasible region so you look at the
intersection of these you know the
interior of these curves and why do you
look at this well because you want the
same true positive rate than the same
false positive rate in both groups so
the shaded region is exactly what you
can realize in both groups ok so this
stuff is not realized I'm realizable in
one group and this stuff stuff is not
realizable in the other group but the
shaded region are the trade-offs that
are realizable in both groups so those
are the ones you can choose from ok and
now if you have a cost function for true
positives and false positives these are
just two numbers your cost for a true
positive and or you cost for false
negative and a false positive once you
have these costs you can just optimize
over the simple two-dimensional region
you heard the word optimize you can just
optimize it's a two dimensional problem
it's pretty trivial you can solve it
with ternary search and you don't need
interior point methods or anything guess
it's an interior point method ternary
search but I'm just making up things ok
and so you know given a cost function
for false positive false negatives you
can just easily find an optimal point in
this feasible region one thing we can
prove about this is that it's optimally
a preservation for preserving
so if our is close to base optimal if
what you start with is close to base
optimal without any fairness constraints
then the output of this post-processing
is close to optimal among all equalized
odds predictors okay so if you start
something that's close to optimal in the
sort of unconstrained region then you
get something that's close to optimal in
the constraint region but that doesn't
mean that it's necessarily good okay
that just means that it's sort of good
in this relative sense but it's not
necessarily you know the right thing to
do
okay and the alternatives to
post-processing are always to collect
more data and just get you know a better
feature set and a better data set and
the other option is to achieve the
constraint at training time and the
second approach has been you know
pursued in the follow-up work but worth
gonna say kahin Asian and cerebro and
last year nips and the idea here is that
you fix a function class H and the loss
function sorry this should be lost
function l and you solve this
optimization problem I've solved the
expected loss of you know my predictor
or my score function from this class age
with respect to the target y subject to
the equalized odds constraint and you
can probably tell that this is like a
hard optimization problem because what
the heck does this constraint even mean
okay so they point out that this is
actually np-hard and so they introduced
a nice you know moment relaxation of
equalized odds which is what you get if
you imagine that all these variables are
Gaussian and you enforce equalized odds
on a set of Gaussian variables then you
just get a moment constraint so you get
a constraint on the covariance that the
covariance of these rare variables and
it would read something like this okay
so you get this moment constrained and
this one is actually a lot more
tractable and so if you're looking for
concrete engagement point for some nice
optimization problems I suggest you look
at this paper because there's some good
stuff in it okay cool and I should also
point out that you know trade-offs are
necessary okay so you can't just
magically sort of hope to get all these
different criteria at once okay so if
you assume the groups have different
rates of positive
outcomes which means that you know
they're more currently they're more male
software engineers than female often
software engineers this is sort of what
the rate of positive outcomes would mean
in this in this example I gave and you
assume your classifier is non-trivial so
the true positive rate is at least zero
and it's imperfect so it's false
positive rate is at least zero so it
makes some true positives and it makes
some false positives and then these
general assumptions which kind of what
you always have you have to choose
between equalized odds or a precision
parity okay so you can either have
equalized odds or you can equalize the
precision values in each group but you
can't have both but differently if you
like achieve you know equal precision as
in the example I gave so your precision
values are the same in each group you're
not going to have equalized odds and you
can ensure that okay so ensuring
equalized odds generally breaks
precision parity and vice versa okay so
this shows that you know we need to
resolve these things through you know
some kind of you know understanding of
the domain and which constrained we
actually want okay we can't kind of just
have everything that we we might hope
for okay so how am i doing on time by
the way I have 20 minutes left okay so
this was observed by tilde Java last
year and there's a similar trade-off for
score functions Deuter Kleinberg molina
ton and Raghavan but it's in the same
spirit okay so people have really cared
about these these trade-offs I can
actually give you the proof because it's
just a very simple proof you assume that
everything holds okay so you have
unequal rates of positive outcomes
called that PA in each group a is your
own one and assume you have equalized
odds so your true positive rate and the
false positive rate is the same in each
group and assume that the cheapy a true
positive rate is greater than zero and
the false positive rate is also greater
than zero and without lots of generally
one of the group and one of the groups
needs to have at least a nonzero chance
of a positive outcome so I might as well
assume that P sub 0 is greater than zero
and so given that I assume everything
holds I want to show you that precision
parity fails okay I have all the
Tiare wand and all the assumptions I
want so I'm going to show you that the
last thing that's missing precision
parody fails okay so I can't have the
same precision value in each group okay
so how is the proof work it's proof by
Wikipedia you take any of these terms
and you google them and you click on the
first Wikipedia link and it gives you a
formula for the precision value it's
going to tell you that the precision in
Group A or generally the precision value
is equal to something in terms of the
true and false positive grade and it's
you know specifically the true positive
rate times P sub a divided by the true
sub true positive for a time's the base
rate plus the false positive rate times
1 minus the base rate and as you can see
if you think about it this term you know
TPR is something that's fixed for each
group but P sub a Val you know varies
because I assumed an unequal rate of
positive outcomes so P sub a is
different for each group right and what
does that mean it means this ratio
varies with a is not the same value for
different A's and so in particular if we
have equal precision if we want to set
these values equal you know for 0 & 1
group 0 & 1 then the only way that could
happen is if TP are 0 or if FP are 0 but
I ruled those out by assumption okay so
that's it okay both are ruled out by
assumption and so these values can
actually be the same for the two groups
that's a proof proof by Wikipedia is
pretty powerful there's a lot of good
stuff on Wikipedia good this is great
okay and so as you know Christopher
already mentioned there's been this
compassed debate the public article and
it really boiled down to this trade-off
okay so Republicans main charge was that
black defendants experience the higher
false positive rate and Northpoint the
creator of these compact scores came
back and said well wait a minute we know
that and it's a corollary of you know
our score satisfying precision parity
roughly okay so Northpoint had a was
correct in asserting that if you have
precision parity you can't have this but
it's still probably I said you know this
is unfair you know what
gonna do about this okay so you're gonna
have these trade offs and to help you
visualize these trade offs a little bit
better a couple of years ago at Google
we build a tool to visualize some of
these fairness trade-off so if you go to
research at Google complex big picture
you'll get to a visualization and
interactive visualization that lets you
explore these things and get a feeling
for why certain things that are just
mutually exclusive and you can't have
them and how different thresholds affect
so if the utility that you get and the
constraints that you can hope to get so
what we've seen yeah in principle it
would be easy to modify to do that but
we didn't we didn't do that so it has a
fixed sort of generative model that you
can explore but yeah we've been meaning
to extend it to other scenarios and
datasets that you can upload it would I
suggested this as a course project for
my fairness class and the students were
like is that publishable so you know
it's I guess it's not you can't you
can't publish it so it's not going to
happen
good so what we've seen so far
let me summarize so there are these
formal form of fairness criteria or one
on discrimination discrimination
criteria that people have articulated
and there are trade-offs between these
and other classification criteria and
certainly as computer scientists and
technical folks we can study how to
achieve them and how they trade off okay
so we can now go you know off the deep
end and just sort of prove more and more
trade offs and approximate versions and
how to optimize these things and and all
that that stuff okay so it seems like
it's it's it's all great but there's
actually a fundamental issue that we
noticed when we were working on this
which is that all these criteria that
we've seen so far are observational okay
so what does observation will mean gonna
make it precise in a moment but
intuitively it just means these are sort
of passive observations about the world
and the distribution the data that you
have right now and there's sort of no
what-if scenarios or interventions you
don't sort of you know consider things
like what if I change the police force
allocation how would that change my data
you know maybe that is the problem right
maybe I should collect more features and
see what happens if I collected more
features
it's not just Corvettes versus Priuses
but I should actually look at you know
additional things like where are they
parked and what time of the day it is
and maybe I should change the data I
have right but there's no sort of no
experimentation with the environment in
this passive view of the world okay and
this needs to inherent limitations I'm
going to tell you so what's an
observational criterion formally a
criterion is observational if it's a
property of the Joint Distribution of
the features X and you're sensitive R
attribute a your classifier C and an
outcome Y and E or the target variable Y
so in other words practically an
observational criterion is anything you
can write down as a probability
statement involving only those four
random variables and certainly
everything I wrote down was just a
probability statement with some identity
of probabilities involving these four
random variables okay in particular or I
even only used a C and y I didn't even
use X but you can throw an X and you
still have what's called an
observational criteria criterion okay
does that make sense people have served
at this point people are usually like
what is a non observational criterion
right what is something that is not this
right and so we're so sort of used to
this point of view that it's hard to
imagine something that's that's not this
okay but let me tell you why this is
unsafe issue were insufficient for
resolving you know questions of fairness
conclusively and I'm going to tell you
that in fact there are two scenarios
with identical joint distributions on
these four random variables but
completely different interpretations for
fairness and this is kind of this
tension between sort of social
interpretation and technical criteria
okay so I'm going to give you two
scenarios where sort of our our
discourse on these two scenarios would
be very different or a sort of opinion
on these things would would vary greatly
but technically formally they mapped to
the same Joint Distribution over these
four random variables so any
observational criterion you can write
down is not going to distinguish between
these two scenarios that human beings
will find very different okay so let me
tell you what these scenarios are
and they go back actually you you
mentioned a few of those those points
before so let me let me tell you what
the first scenario is okay so in the
first scenario there's gender and gender
influences whether you are a programmer
or not or whether you become a
programmer or not they're certainly like
some correlation between you know gender
and being a programmer being a software
engineer right now
so in this probabilistic graphical model
notation that I didn't know what it
means you can draw an arrow from a to Y
and I guess we can tell the audience
afterwards what these arrows mean but so
okay so basically the way I read this is
that you know a sort of you could even
like think about it as sort of causal in
a sense that you know gender sort of
influences whether you become a
programmer or not and I've also heard
that if you are a programmer you like to
go to github.com and you know submit
pull requests and things like this is
that roughly true or do we have any
programmers here okay but I hear github
Commons is great for programmers so if
you're a programmer you might go to
github.com and this becomes my first
feature
okay so x1 is my first feature whether
you visited github com
but there's a second feature which is
whether you visited Pinterest comm this
is x2 and who here visited Pinterest in
the last year okay okay people are
messing with me this was the Stanford I
call this the Stanford effect people
were noticing that I've made a was going
to make the point that you know
Pinterest has a female bias so all the
men raise their hand to like mess up my
point but basically it's still true that
Pinterest has a significant sort of
female bias and they're more female
visitors than men so in principle I can
sort of use Pinterest as a proxy for
gender okay so I'm also going to look at
Pinterest and so what's the what's the
optimal predictor going to do the base
optimal predictor if you will it's going
to look at both of these features and it
says well certainly I'm going to use get
up calm because that's like clearly
predictive of programmer but I'm also
going to be sneaky and I'm gonna say
well look if you use it at Pinterest
calm that makes you more likely to be
female which makes you less likely to be
a programmer okay so it's going to go
they have this like indirect route of
like in for inference
where it says you know I'm going to go
through this proxy to like adjust my
estimate or my prediction of whether or
not you're a programmer that's what the
optimal predictor would do the optimal
equalized odds predictor would say well
wait a minute I can't actually use
Pinterest because this is not separated
from the sensitive attribute why why
right it's directly connected but get up
comma separated from a by Y so there's
this chain here right so it's separated
by Y so I can still use get up calm that
directly predict the future but I can't
use the proxy okay so in this scenario
you know most people would say well what
equalized odds is doing is pretty
reasonable in particular it doesn't use
the proxy it doesn't use gender it seems
like a pretty reasonable thing whereas
this this one's a little bit sneaky
right you would probably if you had to
scrutinize this you would say it's
actually using a proxy and based on that
proxy for gender it's like adjusting its
predictions so in this scenario this one
would be sneaky this would probably be
like even legally defensible and/or
defendable and this this that's probably
not OK scenario 2 the following is true
again you have gender and you have the
target variable programmer but now
there's a chain from gender through to
programmer that goes through whether or
not you obtain the CS degree and so
basically what this chain means is that
I assume that conditional on obtaining a
CS degree you're equally likely to go on
to become a program or whether you're
female or not but you know you're less
likely to obtain a CS degree in the
first place if you're female at least as
of today and so you know there's
correlation between a and Y but it sort
of goes through this variable CS degree
which kind of explains why there is this
bias and there's a second feature
whether you've been to the Grace Hopper
conference I'm not going to ask again
because people know where this going but
you know basically you know this is
again something that has a female bias
so I could again use X to sort of as a
proxy for for gender let's look at what
the optimal constraint predictor at the
optimal unconstrained predictor is doing
the base optimal predictor in this
scenario it would only use x1 ok why
would it only use x1 somebody who
actually understands these arrow notte
this era notation would tell be able to
tell me why the optimal predictor in the
scenario would not use x2 or a avi yeah
because you you know the arrow notation
okay not well okay so if I if I
understand this arrow notation correctly
it basically means you know look a and a
and X are disconnected from Y by this
node CS degree okay so given C is degree
you learn nothing about why that's not
already in CS degree from these
variables okay so that's what this
graphical model means given CS these
become irrelevant for the purpose of
predicting the Y okay so the optimal
thing would not use them because they're
they're useless given CS on the other
hand the equalized odds predictor would
actually say well wait a minute
CS degree is not disconnected from a by
Y okay right there's this direct link
here it's not disconnect it's not
separated by Y so I can't actually just
go and use x1 that's not okay I need to
sort of actively correct the bias that's
in x1 the gender bias next one and well
how do I actively correct the gender
bias in x1 I need to look at explicitly
look at a gender and kind of subtract
things out to make things cancel okay so
the optimal equalized odds predictor
here would be a little bit contrived and
probably people would argue with it it
would kind of explicitly use gender to
kind of remove some gender bias the next
one okay so this in error it's kind of
reversed right so we most people would
be fine with the optimal unconstraint
predictor in fact legally this is
probably what you want to do in this
case and the optimal e.coli starts
predictor would actually do something
that is a little bit weird it would
explicitly use gender to adjust the
thresholds okay and that something
people would maybe not feel comfortable
with
[Music]
yeah that's sort of the interpretation
of it so this is sort of you know here's
a feature also somehow the law doesn't
explicitly resolve what you should do
here right it's just there's an
interpretation of it which you know
lawyers would be able to tell you about
right and yeah they would you know not
one your predictor to directly depend on
either the sensitive attribute or a
proxy for it
so if they find out that you say
Pinterest as a proxy for gender they
would also say well you can't do that
and here you could probably make a case
that this is directly relevant for your
prediction tasks and it doesn't you know
directly use a right that's right so
this is what I'm saying this is an
interpretation right this is what you
know people think you should do on legal
grounds to protect yourself from you
know disparate impact down the road or
issues claims of discrimination which I
don't think would be what it
accomplishes right so I agree that's
currently sorry yeah so right now
there's like an open tension between
what you know formal criteria would
suggest you do and what currently the
practice of or the interpretation of the
law suggests you do it's it's an open
conflict is certainly true and not just
with this notion like any anything
people have proposed along the lines of
fairness would be in conflict all right
and so what you can prove about these
scenarios is they actually admit
identical joint distributions so no
observational criterion can distinguish
them that's pretty shocking in some
sense because it says you know if you
were okay with the optimal predictor in
one case then by any observational
criterion you would also be okay in the
second case and the same for equalized
odds so you know I think there's like
really these two scenarios are very
different and you probably you know we
could go on and talk about them for long
time Warda getting into this discussion
they seem very different to us but no
observational criterion can even like
distinguish them at all no you do you do
you observe the whole distribution
everything you have the entire joint
distribution of all the features all the
you know the predictor we can can even
have a white box you know it's not it's
not about not observing something and so
you observe everything that's what it's
called observational you observe the
entire Joint Distribution and these
these two things map to the same Joint
Distribution even though they have their
socially very different all right
so let me wrap up because I'm running
out of time so we're career is like what
is formally different about these
scenarios and how can we resolve the
indistinguishability and so in recent
jerk showing work with folks from the
Max Planck Institute in tubing and we
actually came up with a causal framework
for reasoning about discrimination based
on sensitive characteristics and the
paper is very much along the lines you
know let's entertain for a moment the
idea of using causality to resolve these
issues where would they get you because
it's not necessarily saying this is what
you should do it's just starting to
explore that avenue of research you know
what happens if you frame the this
problem of non-discrimination from a
causal perspective and I don't have time
to go into it but basically the role of
causality in my opinion is that it
shifts attention to understanding the
data and its generating process okay so
you know causality in some sense it
requires you to make strong assumptions
or have strong insights about how the
data is generated so not just the
distribution that you observe but
actually how it was sort of mechanically
generated okay so it's a little bit like
physics you need to understand your
domain to make to to to proceed right
and so that can be used to articulate
things like interventions and and sort
of what-if scenarios and that can
mitigate limitations of some
observational criterias a criteria but I
should say that you know causality is
certainly not always practical would you
agree with that statement
sure okay okay so okay but I kind of
came to like that that it's not always
practical because maybe you know machine
learning is not always the right thing
to do without a causal understanding of
your domain
maybe we shouldn't just blindly apply
you know machine learning to everything
that comes across and you know just put
everything squeeze everything in this
into this prediction paradigm maybe in
some cases we actually want a
substantive substantive understanding of
the domain before we proceed right and
cause le kind of directs your attention
to to that part or to that problem so in
conclusion I would say that observation
criteria can help Biskit discover
discrimination or point you in to sort
of things that are going to be perceived
as unfair but they're insufficient on
their own so don't accept a conclusive
claim of fairness or unfairness based on
observational criteria I just don't
think that's what they're what they're
there for and again I should also say
that fairness criteria are meaningless
if your variables are poorly defined or
measured if your target variable is
poorly specified like instead of Aria
rest or instead of committing a crime
you use real rest which is heavily
biased all these criteria become
meaningless okay so we need to
understand I understand about the
definition of the variables that we look
at and how they were measured and that's
going to reveal a lot of issues which
are also not captured by observational
criteria okay and so ultimately I don't
think that you know any of this is going
to replace human scrutiny and expertise
and to me it's more about how can we
come up with formal mechanisms that
highlight issues to human experts in the
right way how can we guide and and
support human experts and in under era
understanding these problems cool and so
you know the cause of framework can help
to articulate some of these problems and
organize assumptions that we can make
and I think it's useful in that regard
as for concrete technical problems I
don't really have much but you know
better optimization algorithms for
achieving up to observation criteria
such as equalized odds a training time I
think is an interesting direction and
trade-off results for approximate
criteria so instead of having these
exact things you ask what if I relaxed
them what kind of trade-offs do I get I
think these are two very concrete and
and reasonable problems to study
as for broader research directions you
know we can explore the space of causal
analogs of observational criteria and
see how they trade off I think that's
completely you know wide open and I want
to understand how we can utilize weak
qualitative causal information let's say
social scientists tell you well I think
this variable is causal for that but
they're not going to tell you exactly
how the data was generated they're not
going to give you a structural equation
model for your data how can we utilize
that to make our insights more robust
and one thing I've been working on which
I'm particularly intrigued by is sort of
temporal dynamics which is suppose
there's some criterion you want to
achieve in the long run what is kind of
the near-term intervention or near-term
constraint that we should design to get
that desired long term outcome so rather
than thinking about this problem as kind
of one-shot thing you know you set up
your your prediction problem and it's
over do you think about it as a repeat
at a repeated process something that's
applied over and over again and then you
draw the distinction between constraints
that you place on the predictor and long
term criteria that you want to achieve
and that leads to an interesting
distinction that's currently missing in
the in the area and a lot of new
technical questions all right I think
that's all that's all I got
thanks
[Applause]
okay can you give an example how you did
these causal fidelity into this in one
of those examples yeah so in these
examples you know basically you can
interpret all these arrows as sort of
causal like and you know links in a
causal graph like you can you can
basically create a formalism that you
know allows you to basically if you have
like a link like this you know some node
you know let's say CSX one goes to Y you
know you could actually flip this value
right like if you have a chain like this
a you could actually say what if I make
people study CS against their natural
inclination okay so I said X 1 to 1
right so I like you know divided this
room into two groups and a force you
know one of the two groups you know to
study CS so you might have to go and
study CS maybe that's what you already
did I don't know but on you know go back
to school study CS see what happens
right so it allows me a causal graph
allows me to actually sort of entertain
these what if scenarios okay so what if
you know inserted a certain value for
this variable and I sort of looked at
how this affected things downstream and
that's basically formally what causality
boils down to in this setting and that's
a more powerful mechanism because it's
really a you know it allows you to look
at things you know it allows you to look
at things that don't happen by
themselves you know it allows you to
sort of break natural inclination people
behave the way they are but causality
that kind of lets you consider you know
these interventions that you don't get
if you just observe natural behavior
oh yeah sure sure no and sort of you
know this link is very delicate right
like sort of when you one of the
weaknesses of causality is that you know
if you wanted to turn this into you know
causal you know or a structural equation
model you would actually have to think
about how this variable x1 is sort of
generated from a and that's certainly
you know I don't know right and social
scientists are not going to tell you
right answer there's a lot of weight
there are a lot of ways for causality go
wrong because we don't actually know how
sort of what the causal link is between
gender and CS right and so it leads to a
whole nother range of problems that you
know you create a stronger formalism
that requires you to make in some sense
much stronger assumptions and it's not
necessarily clear how you can get to
that point how you can have enough
understanding of your domain to really
write down these things
yeah so there's there's a lot of
literature on you know when can you
infer causal links from observational
data there's a set of established
conditions and ongoing work and so in
those cases you don't necessarily need
to make those assumptions you might you
know be able to infer it from from the
data you have that's one possibility
wasn't the graphical model directed in
that case as well so you were also using
your directive it was a direct a
graphical model yeah no it does not
right so a directed graphical model just
kind of describes the independence
conditional independence information
that's all it does and conditional
independence is a property of the
drawing distribution no no no so like an
directed graphical model
property of your Joint Distribution in
the sense that the only thing encodes
our independence assumptions conditional
independence assumptions same as
undirected it gives you like a little
bit more sort of information about how
things would factor I guess but it's not
causal directed graphical models not a
causal model causal model it makes
stronger assumptions someone sells the
bride a gear to the TSA to use some deep
net to do facial classification that
just happens you know to pick up people
with darker skins and beards to for
starters all of these observational
criteria black box or you know the ones
I mentioned so those those certainly
apply and that's you know one good thing
about them is that they apply even in
those black box in areas and you can use
them to kind of probe these black box
models to see what what's going on right
yeah if you wanted to then go and come
up with a causal model for you a
scenario that's pretty hard to do and
like especially for you know when your
inputs are pixels right you know it's
it's kind of hard to do causal analysis
based on that
Lucian's of the score functions
conditioned on the protected class so
kind of the proportion of people at any
threshold of protected class a that are
classified as true or you know likely to
default or whatever is similar to the
proportion of people of protected class
B that are likely to default is there
some kind of similar interpretation in
terms of distributions or
equal-opportunity so I'm not sure I
completely understand the question but I
think you you know first of all
equalized odds is conditioning on the
outcome right it's looking at you know
the positive outcomes and the negative
outcomes in each group and comparing
distributions across that variable it so
it's it's it's not conditioning on the
protected attributes conditioning on the
I guess these conditioning on both but I
think the important part is conditioning
on the target variable which is also
what Equal Opportunity does it's just
that it only looks at the positive group
the positive outcome group and not the
negative outcome group but they don't
want to target conservative verses so
you could say that okay well whatever
threshold we'll use you want to make
sure that a similar proportion of
liberal posts are classified as fake
news as conservative posts yeah so that
doesn't qualify as equal odds it
certainly does it's it's it's you know
that's just what it is right you would
say that you know you would say you mean
make your predicted attribute you know
whether it's you know conservative or
liberal and then you would just say your
target is you know being let's say
unfiltered IQ being shown and then you
want that good content in each group has
legitimate content in each group has the
same you know show rate so that's just
that would just be equal opportunity
okay so I guess then my question will be
flipped then is there some kind of
distributional interpretation of people
lots yeah I don't know what you mean by
that but there is I mean it's just this
conditional independence thing right to
me is that's a distributional
interpretation I don't I don't know I
guess I don't understand the question
yeah let's let's take it offline I'm
probably slow to get it thanks
[Applause]